the Thanksgiving holiday travel period
is officially underway this morning pack
your patience people play abroad
projects nearly 51 million Americans
will travel 50 miles or more over this
period now this is the highest number
since 2005 about 89% of those travelers
will be driving Kris Van Cleave is in a
car in Washington Chris good morning but
you're not behind the wheel there you go
here's the bad news
yeah good morning here's the good news
the very very worst of this drive
probably happened last night take a look
at this video from Los Angeles you can
see how bad it was
Tuesday night in most major cities the
worst of it the bad news Wednesday
nights not going to be a lot better
triple-a says evenings between 3:00 and
7:00 typically the worst leading up to
Thanksgiving
so best options either leave midday
today or if you can early Thanksgiving
morning and when you leave you are going
to be paying more at the pump gas prices
the highest they've been for
Thanksgiving holiday in three years
national average is two dollars and 54
cents this month that's 37 cents higher
this spike due to the hurricanes we saw
that reduced supply now the best time to
drive home if you can do it in the
morning either Friday morning or Sunday
morning the reason more people are
driving the economy is better
Vlad Kris Van Cleave thank you very much